in Washington more Democrats are
considering the option of impeaching
President Trump now that most of special
counsel Robert mullahs Russia report has
been made public House Democrats plan to
hold a conference call later today to
discuss what Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi calls a grave matter the
president responded on Twitter over the
weekend accusing Democrats our
wrongdoing Paula Reid is at the White
House with the latest on this story
Paula good morning to you good morning
Gail even though the White House is
declaring the Mullah report a total
victory for the president the scrutiny
continues as Democrats refused to take
impeachment off the table
even though party leaders acknowledged
that would be politically risky as
president Trump attended Easter services
in West Palm Beach Special Counsel
Robert Muller avoided questions outside
his church in Washington we testified
before Congress sir it's the first time
we've heard Muller speak since being
appointed special counsel the
president's attorney Rudy Giuliani
insisted it's acceptable to take
information about an opponent from a
foreign adversary that's nothing wrong
with taking information from Russians
though the former prosecutor wouldn't
recommend it I would have advised just
out of excess of caution don't do it
congressman Jerry Nadler question why
Muller did not bring charges against
those in the infamous June 2016 Trump
Tower meeting Donald Trump jr. Jared
Kushner and then Trump campaign manager
Paul Manafort who met with a Russian
lawyer promising dirt on Hillary Clinton
they went to the meeting that's
conspiracy right there but in his report
Muller explained he didn't bring charges
against them because he could not prove
they willfully sought to commit a crime
senator and 2020 hopeful Elizabeth
Warren distinguished herself among her
Democratic rivals by unequivocally
calling for impeachment over the weekend
Constitution
and it says when a president engages in
this kind of activity then it's time for
you but House Oversight Committee
Chairman Democrat Elijah Cummings was
more cautious I'm not there yet but I I
can foresee that possibly coming
Cummings also said he believes the
president could be embolden if Democrats
do nothing but he urged caution before
proceeding with impeachment House
Democrats continue to pursue over a
dozen investigations into the president
and his administration those are
expected to continue through 2020 Nora
all right Paula thank you so much